الان الى تطورتي الحرب في اوكرانيا حيثما
تزال معارك ضخم تشكل العنوان الابرز في
الميدان فقد اكد مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر ان
القوات الروسيه تحاصر بخموت ولا يوجد الا
طريق واحد لخروج القوات الاوكرانيه منها
وكان موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي افاد ان
قوتي فاجنر تقترب من قطع اخر طرق امدادات
الجيش الاوكراني في المدينه الاستراتيجيه
واضاف الموقع ان وحدات فاجنر وصلت الى
الطريق الرابط بين
تراجع القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه الاثناء
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر عسكريه
اوكرانيه قولها ان ميليشيا فاجنر احرز
التقدم الجزئيا في محاولتها للتقدم نحو
قريه خروموفا على المحور الشمالي لمدينه
باخموت واشارت المصادر الاوكرانيه الى ان
المعارك الضاريه مستمره على محورين الشرقي
والجنوبي للمدينه